[Musique]
J'ai eu une vision que
les gens brûlaient
tout détruit, c'était Athéna, elle le
faisait,
je le faisais, nous ne laisserions pas cela arriver, j'ai
vu ce que tu as fait sur le ring,
je savais que ça devait être toi, dis et
si je te le disais.  Sienne, voici la
réincarnation de la déesse Athéna
et vous êtes destinée à devenir l'un de
ses chevaliers gardiens,
qu'est-ce que ça fait d'être une déesse
parfois, j'ai l'impression d'être un invité dans mon
propre corps,
êtes-vous prêt à commencer votre entraînement du
Pégase  la nuit est courageuse,
humble et déterminée à protéger
Athéna de sa vie.
Je t'ai entendu dire
qu'Oasis ne ressemble à aucune autre. Avant que le
temps ne doive nous sauver d'elle,
tu penses que je voulais tout cela,
ses pouvoirs de responsabilité une fois qu'il aura appris
à le contrôler, non.  un homme vivant pourra
s'arrêter,
tu
voudras peut-être attacher ta ceinture,
es-tu la seule nuit en ville